p-f-t-o-t
tuesday edition things we either
couldn't get to or didn't have enough
time to talk to the way
we would like to chris sims mike florio
here with you and uh
chris we just mentioned antonio brown
very briefly he has
said on twitter that he's done with
football he's walking away from the game
the risks are too great yadda yadda look
we've seen this from him before so i
don't know what to take seriously from
him there still is an intense level of
interest in antonio brown
i think people recognize he can still
play at a high level the problem is
no one is signing him and the league has
yet to resolve
three pending personal conduct policy
investigations one of which definitely
will get him suspended he pleaded no
contest to felony charges
in florida as a result of an incident
that happened earlier this year right he
could be suspended for the full season
i really do have a problem with the
nfl's
inability or unwillingness to process
these cases
faster because what happened was antonio
brown missed 14 games last year
because this was hanging over his head
and here we are
almost 11 months after the first
incident the lawsuit that was filed
against him for sexual assault and rape
and he still doesn't know what the
punishment is he
still doesn't know if the league
believes he's guilty and they just
continue
to keep him hanging and and no one wants
him
and so he's throwing his hands up in the
air again i
i i'm i'm done now look maybe he'll
change his mind as he has before
but you know the impediment is still
there would you want him
if i could get him free and clear and if
i knew that if i could get him like with
tom brady not that the buccaneers want
him
with a quarterback that i knew could
control him right on a very
low risk one strike arrangement
yeah i i mean of course he's gonna make
my team better
um if if he's going to do what's
expected of him if he's truly learned
from and been humbled by what's happened
over the course of the last year i i
would be interested in him i know but
it doesn't look like to me that he's
learned anything from it i mean
you know you said it there's you know he
doesn't have a lawyer representing him
in one case
that's an issue with like the property
defamation and the apartment there in
miami that's gonna be still an issue
you know the nfl they that you know
they're scared
they don't want to just not property
property destruction yeah whatever
whatever it is you know what are those d
words all right but either way like
i you know again the nfl doesn't want to
like jump the shark here and just go oh
we think you're okay
and you can come back in the league and
then we find out like more stuff about
them
in some of the pending cases so i think
that's scary from from that stance but
they've had they've had
every chance to investigate this guy
this is what i don't like about the
system
yeah generally they can take as long as
they want
there's no deadlines there's no triggers
there's no
thou shout get the investigation done
within 60 days
and so they can and they the threat of
him being on the commissioner exemplist
has scared everyone away
so he has essentially served a 14 game
suspension already
and they still could suspend him on top
of it so look
i just think that from time to time he
gets exasperated
and he feels like he's helpless and he
feels like he has no control over his
situation
and he's right because the league
continues to refuse
to issue any decisions uh
or impose any discipline for the various
things that the league continues to take
under advisement
yeah we're right you know it just i to
me you know i wouldn't be surprised if
the nfl is deliberately
dragging their feet a little bit with
the guy like antonio brown
just to because you know they don't
believe in his
moral character as of late so they're
not like in a
rush the nfl's gonna be fine without
antonio brown we all watched football
last year when he got suspended and or
was cut by the patriots and
and not in the league i wasn't like oh
i'm not gonna watch this sunday
antonio's not in the league
you know it's going to keep going we
know that the other thing mike i'll just
ask you because i
i don't even know does he have
representation for as an agent right now
because i know drew rosenhaus made those
comments that he was going to drop
him and wasn't going to you know
continue to represent him unless he got
help
and i never really heard more on that
and i haven't dug into it a little to
make calls or figure out what's going on
there
but i just wonder if he even has that
right now at this point in time
i think he does and i'll look it up as
we continue to have the conversation
um look we know the guy can play
and and we know that he has friends in
the league
tom brady continues to have a high
degree of loyalty to antonio brown
russell wilson seems to want antonio
brown in seattle remember last
year when the seahawks signed josh
gordon after he was released by the
patriots
the reports were that it was down to
gordon and antonio brown and the reason
that gordon got the job is he was
available
right with brown who knows when he's
available so um
i i just i just you know the problem is
certain players are not sympathetic
figures and antonio brown is not a
sympathetic figure
so the nfl can mistreat him
right can drag their feet right and no
one cares right
no one's going to stick their neck out
for antonio brown
yeah and the problem is it's just a
horrible precedent to set
it's an abuse of the spirit of this
process that the nfl has put in place to
police the private lives of players and
i guess my point is this
if you're going to police the private
lives of players the things they do away
from work
you owe it to all players to move a
little more quickly than you're moving
and let go where they stand right so
they can get back to making a living
yeah or at least know they need to move
on
right agreed you're right they don't
give any finality or
anything there to give the guy a chance
of what to do with the next move or do i
stay here and just stay status quo
i think that's a brilliant point by you
and you're right
it's not fair from that standpoint even
for a guy like antonio brown who's had a
laundry
laundry list of issues um i don't know i
mean i
i have a feeling this will be the end of
antonio brown and my heart of hearts
mike i don't know how you feel about it
um because i just don't know if a team
will ultimately make that decision to
move on
uh but either way it's it's been a
phenomenal career i mean right he's
he's going to the hall of fame right i
mean i think he's going to the hall of
fame
he's he's i know it's close but he was i
don't know
he's definitely he was one of the two or
three best receivers in football for
i would say what a five five to six year
run
and really i'll tell you the other thing
that just jumps out to me about his
career if this is it
i mean what was he a sixth round pick
you know four years
from michigan six yeah four years in
college like
you know really you don't see nfl
superstar
wide receivers especially who really
ever stay in school past their junior
year it's very rare you see a four-year
college wide receiver be the star of a
team it's really rare
so between that and being a six-round
pick man that he overcomes some odds and
i know he worked hard and worked for it
and he was awesome to watch when he was
in his prime
i would say at one point jj watt and
antonio brown were on the same central
michigan team because that's where what
got started before he transferred
to wisconsin it's that same time frame
but look i don't know about him making
it to the hall of fame we know how
flawed that process is he's gonna have
to wait at a minimum and he's gonna have
to get some redemption at some point i'm
just
frustrated by the fact that you know for
a guy who just
needs help i feel like the nfl has found
a way to freeze him out and they have
him in this weird limbo
and it's almost like let's see him how
much pressure we can put on him
to get him to do more stuff that we can
stack on top
of the things we already are
investigating him for and if we can
frustrate him enough he'll do enough
that we never have to deal with this guy
again
because he didn't want to play ball with
our rules on what helmet you can wear i
just feel like the nfl
still has lingering animosity toward the
guy over that helmet fiasco from last
year
and they've decided in a roundabout way
they don't want him anymore period
uh and you know it's unfortunate for
teams chris because once guys start
testing positive for covet 19
it's not going to be long before his
phone rings if he's available to play
but the problem is he's not available to
play
no yeah you're right i mean it's uh it's
messed up it's something that i
i certainly will take away from this
conversation i'm you're right the nfl's
got to be
a little faster with this type of
process you're ruining people's lives
you're not letting them move on and you
know again you know
antonio brown not to be just i mean he
put on earth to be a receiver in the nfl
i mean that's what he is built to do
and you know you only have so many years
to capitalize off that in your career he
certainly made the mistakes he's got to
pay
pay the price a little bit but you know
how long do you have to pay the price
you're right uh that does bother me
about the nfl so we'll see
but i'm betting he doesn't mike i'm
betting this is it i really think it is
it i don't i don't know why i don't have
a reason but i'm saying
he's done i don't think he's ever gonna
play again either
okay will he will he never rescind
his latest retirement i i'm not ready to
say
that that you know we've heard the last
from antonio brown but i do believe the
nfl has this this
table set in a way that prevents antonio
brown as a practical matter from ever
playing again
uh ed wazileski is the current agent of
record
for antonio brown according to nfl pa
documents so it did go from drew
rosenhouse there was a period
of time where antonio brown was
unrepresented but he does have an agent
not that that is getting him any closer
to playing again especially now that he
for now is retired michael bennett
one of the dominant defensive players of
the last decade is now officially
retired from the nfl
when he was great he was as great as
anyone in the nfl he had those
those little kid ed mccaffrey shoulder
pads oh right he had
i mean bear exposed shoulders right he
wanted to give the offensive lineman
nothing to hold
and uh uh they could not stop him he was
the biggest concern the patriots had in
super bowl 49
by way of what the seahawks had on their
defense and uh you know a great career
for a guy who
as as you know as you say all the time
and this is as you said earlier today
this is the origin of your f up the play
stat yeah he's not going to have a ton
of sacks he's not going to have a ton of
tackles
what he's going to do is blow up the
play and make it easier for his
teammates to get to the ball
right that's exactly right it'd be one
of the more underappreciated players
you know of the 2000s to me is probably
what he's going to go down as
one of my favorite players of the last
decade and yeah i mean you know i know
we talked about it a little bit at the
end of the show
but i think you can make a real argument
you know
that 2013 14 15
even to 2016 you could legitimately say
he was the best defensive player in
football he was unblockable
he really was and i know i mean like you
mentioned you know in america's game
when the patriots had to play the
seahawks that's all they worried about
you know and they had a nickname for him
and i can't remember either but it was
like an endearing name because
he just messed up so many plays and he
was such a headache and i can't remember
what it is off the top of my head here
but yeah i mean he was one of those guys
that
it's really where i on my podcast that's
it's where i started i'd be watching
film people
ask me about seattle and blah blah blah
and i'd go i don't know
i mean seattle is awesome hey bobby
wagner richard sherman you know cam
chancellor amazing
but i was like this 72 guy he
has to play up every freaking play
almost
and bust into the backfield running back
has to stop redirect you know
tackle for a one-yard loss you know drop
back quarterback
oh man he's got to abandon the pocket
somebody else gets the sack or it's an
inconvenient pass
let me go rewind that play oh well
that's michael bennett split a double
team right up the middle
in the face of the quarterback ruin the
play so uh phenomenal phenomenal
football player
and um a great guy to be around i like
being around the bennett brothers and i
really like being michael bennett he is
extremely smart thoughtful and you know
make you he'll make people think that's
for sure he really is a deep thinker
that way
he really did deserve more credit than
he got he made it to the pro bowl three
times 2015 2016-2017 who was the nfc
defensive player of the week one time in
his career
and i think this is very telling even
though i'm not a big fan of the nfl's
annual top 100 players of any given year
list i think it's
it's kind of a flawed process what they
do is they they
they distribute a sheet of paper right
to a bunch of players and say list the
top 20 guys in the nfl and they cobble
that together into a list of 100 guys
he was 90th in 2015 which is ridiculous
59th in 2016 and 46th in 2017 and i
think he just gets forgotten if you tell
somebody
list the top 20 players in the nfl even
when michael bennett was at his peak
you're not going to think of him because
he doesn't get a lot of press he didn't
have a lot of numbers
he's not a guy that you think of when
you're only thinking of a handful of
players even though
he should have been right the guy that
you're thinking of and if it's a guy
that bill belichick is thinking of
when he's got all those great seahawks
defensive players he's got to contend
with
and the first guy that he needs to
neutralize is michael bennett
that tells you all you need to know
about how good michael bennett was yeah
that's exactly right it tells you all
you need to know
and it's it's you know with belichick
yeah he's the notable one but man i know
a lot of coaches back in that day they
were always like man this michael
bennett this michael bennett i mean
he was a guy you had a legitimately game
plan for you couldn't leave your guard
man-to-man on michael bennett too often
you know he was really a defensive end
who had the strength to play defensive
tackle
and that's where he was really rare i
mean you know he's
280 pounds maybe high 270s
but it's unbelievable his strength and
his ability to be
slippery and just slide you know get
skinny as we say in the nfl there's a
gap and he could go through like this
and just shoot through because he had
unbelievable explosion
and i think that's the big reason he
wore those shoulder pads mike
because he felt like you know just gave
an offensive lineman less
area to really get their hands and
gloves on to where it could you know
impede his movements and things and it's
amazing he played football that long and
never had
that just tells you what a beast he was
that he could play in those shoulder
pads and never even be hurt or anything
bothered by it
undrafted out of texas a m with the
seattle seahawks in
2009 for a brief period of time then
with the tampa bay buccaneers joined the
seahawks after becoming a free agent
in tampa his best years were with the
seahawks 2013 through 2017
one year with the eagles one year with
the patriots not even a full year with
the patriots part of a year with the
patriots and then finished his career
with the dallas cowboys
but yeah for that that that narrow
window
2014 through 2017 one of the finest
defensive players in all of football
and it's just it's unfortunate that he
didn't get more credit because i don't
think he's going to be remembered chris
the way that he should be
when you think back of the guys that
have played over the last 15 20 years
it's amazing when you're reminded of
different names of guys you've just
completely forgotten about you remember
the stars right there are a lot of guys
who have played that you forget about
my concern is he's going to fall into
that that vat
of guys that 10 15 years from now people
forget about yeah you're right you know
it makes me i'm interested here just you
know did he make the
all decade team you know no yeah i know
you know
that's that's that's unbelievable too
you know i'd have a hard time you know i
understand aaron donald he's certainly
got to be on there other defensive
tackles i can't remember who the other
defensive tackle was on the all decade
team
but michael bennett would be one of
those guys who you know i
i think could have been in that
conversation and just unfortunate it's
it's again it goes into the
you know the stats era and that's what
we are really in people just look at
stats as a bottom line thing and they
don't look at the context of
the situation and what he did and how he
affected the game
and everything like that and so often
with these type of guys too they don't
get their credit
until they're almost past their prime
like you know
like you said 2017 he's 46
best player in the nfl and the end of
like he should have been the 46th best
player at the end of the 2013 season i
mean
you go back watch the you know the
broncos super bowl and that playoff run
you know with michael bennett that year
when when the seahawks beat them
he was all over the place they're just
an absolute nightmare so
uh yeah you're right it's one thing i've
realized mike doing this show with you
the last few years
every now and then we bring up a name
and i think i'm with you i think michael
bennett could be that name 10 years from
now where you go
damn he was a good player gosh i forgot
about him
wow he was good you know it's just it's
unreal but if you don't make the hall of
fame or you're not one of those big
superstars it just doesn't seem to
stick in your brain the same way four
all-decade defensive ends and
four all-decade defensive tackles the
defensive ends caleus campbell
cam jordan julius peppers jj watt
the defensive tackles geno atkins
fletcher cox aaron donald and dominic
and sue ooh
yeah man i really i like to see i love
gino atkins he's a baller but that like
i'd probably look at that
and go i probably would have gave
michael bennett the edge over geno
atkins
and i i think the world of geno atkins
but i mean bennett
you know to me was borderline
unblockable there for about a four year
period
what about calais campbell michael
bennett well i know
yeah that's a it's a good one too well
what i would really want to argue there
is calais campbell
is a defensive tackle really but he's
played in a 3-4 scheme where they listed
defensive end as the position
because they do things differently that
way and that's to me where the
conversation sometimes and this type of
stuff gets
a little mixed up too i mean claes
campbell is not
like you know oh we want you to come off
the edge and just do that play after
play after play after play he can do
that because he's a
a specimen but yeah i think he's more d
tackle than he is d
end yeah you know a lot of times with dt
and d
when you get into these lists they get
all screwed up the bottom line there
were eight defensive linemen on the all
deck 8 team and none of them michael
bennett and i think he could make a case
that he maybe should have had
one of those spots all right uh that's
it for
pft ot on this tuesday we'll be back on
wednesday with more pft live
profootballtalk.com around the clock
plenty of stuff happening in the nfl as
they get everything lined up chris the
money is next i think
they get the money worked out we'll be
ready to go for football season and then
we just have to hope that
that the uh the league in the union
pandemic please
victor let there be football good day
man
you know i think there will be i'm
starting to get optimistic i'm feeling
good
i think they're going to work it out i
think we're going to have it i'm with
you i'm with you we'll see you tomorrow
with me
me tomorrow today i feel good all right
everybody have a great day we'll see you
wednesday see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports